hi I miss I'm Italian I'm a scientist
cutter biomedical research institute
Qatar Foundation and that's just a
professor at Harvard University in Qatar
today I would like to talk about
generating pancreatic beta cell
precursors from human pluripotent stem
cells for cell therapy so in this
presentation I'm going to talk about
spend a few minutes to talk about
diabetes and available options or a
little option to treat diabetic patients
and then I will discuss the recent
progress and the challenges in using
stem cells for generating Bank beta
cells and then I will talk about the
incredible example and they'll use for
treating diabetic patients and I will
finish my presentation with - by
summarizing some of our published work
and the graphic version others
diabetes davidon is a metabolic disorder
characterized by chronic hyperglycemia
due to release applause or impaired
functional pancreatic beta-cells type
one diabetes
characterized by a pitiful loss due to
edobean defect with subsequent rows of
insulin secretion but type 2 is
different which is the represent the 95
percent of diabetic patients compared to
the greater beta cell failure appears
you too long or due to insulin to do to
insulin resistance in insulin target
tissue which and then the bitter cells
try to overcome the insulin resistance
so they become exhausted so in case in
both cases we can so fill therapy since
this is a technically fit with more with
type 1 because in table you do have beta
cell and then in advantage cases of type
2 the patient lost most of their beta
cells so what are the sources or
possible sources of beta cell for two
possible sources to get the result for
therapy
um that
the plantation of controller pancreas
it's one source for interpretation of
pancreatic islet cells and genetically
engineered a human man pick ourselves
you can convert the numbers of the into
beta cells like alpha to beta and other
cell types and also beat the crowd or
islets from non-human source like
vinegar acts like a facial big
and enhance it because of application
leakage of the patients can have some
data cells in particular inside too and
the last option is to use stem cells to
generate pancreatic beta cells today
either the presentation is the most to
date the translational I pilots so we
mean the most effective approach for
reveled in hyperglycemia diabetic
patients
however this approach has limitations
the problem with this although it is
effective but still in half limitations
such as not enough pancreatic islet to
meet the demand for one patient unique
to three donors immediate side effect of
using stronger neural suppressant in
case while presentation and all donor
pancreas and also return to internal
requirement again and dangers of
transplantation procedures so we believe
that stem cells private eyelid so maybe
can be with would solve this kind of
problems or concerns
so human pancreas be forced to start to
talk about the pluripotent stem cell in
for cell therapy diabetes would like to
talk about human pancreas to understand
how that the beta cells how it works in
banking or banking the islet of
Langerhans
a clapper observes with eyelids
containing around 3,000 to 4,000 so
there are only 1 million is in the
healthy about pancreas they make up only
around 1 to 2 percent of the entire
banker because impaired organ
so the normal Bank has has about 1
million eyes 80% of this can be lost
before develop diabetes so the patient
can survive or can before before to
develop the sentence 20% is enough to to
not feel that or also not be diagnosed
as the the diabetic so to be able to use
beta cells from stem cells first we have
to understand the human pancreatic
beta-cell development
so what we are doing in case of her una
corbata stem cells immigrants important
stem cells become the cabbage tulips
human pancreatic development to generate
insulin-secreting beta salts so
therefore we concerned that that human
clone essential dreaded pancreatic cells
they have a great potential to be used
for diabetic David's treatment so what
we do use the skin voice differentiation
protocols designed to mimic pancreatic
development to generate beta cells by
directing them along with the stages of
develop into their the stereo the
primitive got you Bustillo for that
pancreatic progenitors tancredi
endocrine presenters immature beta cell
and finally be resolved and we every
stage characterized by very specific
group of transcription factors all the
little stages during development its
we'll study because able to give the
founded the early stage of human
pancreatic we dilute our neutral status
for several reasons for the shorten is
very difficulty with samples at very
early stages around is than one month
after pregnancy and also due to
difficult concern
so is it possible to obtain functional
data cells in vitro this is the main
question here
so until 2014 so ministers given the
study showed generation beta filling be
true but this showed showed immature
phenotypes so what it is in that your
phenotypes immaterial phenotypes that
twisting delay exhibit some marker
because a lack of original xsplit all
markers they are putting good model
they don't expose only incident where
the expose also other hormones like
crystal water step in and the glucagon
and when you challenge the mozilla code
they are not responding table cost
however if you use the same protocol but
drugs a gland cut through a kinetic
collision occurs but in specific
comparative velocity which I call
Express tune important transcription
factors cause BD x 1 and n EK 6.1 they
find that we found that the cells become
mature inside the animal enjoy use the
same protocol so think that the micro
environment enviable the signaling
pathway effect on maturation so we don't
know what are the signal pathway and
what are the characteristic of this
match your deeper self exhibit approved
Peter cell marker and present rampant
the admin Ramona's discrete any insulin
not not other hormone and really
challenging which will correspond to
glucose appropriately but recently a
shaniyah in died douglas burgers
Mountain at Harvard and other groups
they claim that or they showed that they
were able to generate functional
pancreatic beta cells in vitro
so digit the example of this
applications the most important
applications that we show the ability to
generate functional by yourself
Oh to publish in cell 2014 October 2014
and what machine hfj technology in the
1.14 and also the last day we'll publish
it so
examples that claim that you able to
generate function and beta cell however
still have challenges to generate fully
functional created paper cells to three
diabetic patients
the in dental methylation is still a bit
take problems Victor the protein
responsiveness
also they claim that the the generated
functional good result and it's true but
the efficiency is very low and there are
sensors that are responding to the locos
they are still not enough for
consultation therapy that the partition
efficient as I mentioned the
heterogeneity which because some of your
tips are not big ourselves at five seven
and not be the third stage also they
they they where you have some functional
phenotype but it can be able to create
some key transcription factors and the
ability to maintain them individual
basically is still difficult so you have
to find a way to maintain them from
internal culture so we agreed that a lot
of work need to be done to obtain
frontal and table function beta so
individual
so now we talked about what are the
challenges for do you pick a cell for
therapy can as I mentioned in previous
slides we talked about the graphic
believers of cell transplantation we can
give functional eyelid or paper cells
inside the body of the animal models so
what are the target and kinetic
potential that can be generated in
brittle from plottable that stem cells
it is known that we can generate
originated which does just presented
don't express any cake 60.1 but the
figures only bx1
and ourselves we never give functional
details we always give polymer moanin so
basically insolence
look at God and so much to him but and
sometimes they give also salt but we
never give functional because of the
other type of unity is the double border
BT x1 and any cake 6.1 there are
critical transcription factors we must
be considered in the same cells to be
able to give functional manova more than
secreting only insulin beta cells and
guess - so - presenter are normally
existed during normal development in
Engelmann do we have other presenters we
believe in our lab that we we believe
that it's we have a new progenitor
because we recently we publish we
reported that the in vitro generation of
another population which is expressing
in the case of support 1 only and
negative for the gives one but the
functionality of those projectors is not
known yet why we believe this is a
percent because it is known that in kHz
6.1 is required for Digital development
and the insulin secretion process and in
human in the case export one is
exclusive for beta cells which is
different from ours now indicatrix 420
is involved in Alpha and the beta cells
I will explain more and coming slide
about this new version of ourselves
so the importance of of pancreatic
progenitor so it is very clear that very
important since it only help now use the
clinical trial by biocides so in 2017
besides we got approval in 2014 so if EA
to use this progenitors and to
transplant them into a diabetic patient
so it's a second student in website
unknown the allowance of
limited system of human Bunica stem
cells rabbit or created progenitor for
step one diabetic patient because anyway
we have autoimmune the Fetzer is not
important to be patient specific and
they made sure that this project will
express both transcription factors
and the migrants encapsulate them in
what's called in cut in capture a cell
delivery system the trial is now
underway in the USA and Canada so the
clinical trial for evaluating the safety
and efficacy of therapeutic use and
tilaka type 1 diabetic patients inside
the body they demanded that the after
consultation under the scan with a
unique these parameters will be
converted into small I'll basically we
have insulin-secreting cells mono
hormone and glucagon and somatostatin
and then we will respond to glucose
facility and encapsulated that we will
respond to glucose in the blood and that
we have two types of capsules one
capsule without the cannot that the
blood cell cannot enter inside and the
new capsule that with that blood cells
or to the block cabela's can penetrate
them to the device but you need the news
of recent in this case in this case we
the vendor that Lucas that will not be
able to get that inside the body and
type the inside the encapsulation system
and we will only delete insulin response
to glucose so
from this it's very clear that the
gravity who can be used in the future in
the new future for treatment so now our
we come to our work
while much focus has been assigned to
determine determining the appropriate
site you can cocktail to differentiate
or to mimic in vivo
development the impact of modulating
adventure culture conditions that affect
the cell physically environment as
plating dynasty cell-cell contact and
the drawbacks of the extracellular
matches on the graphic difference is not
valid so in our war what we did we
manipulated
check conditions we were able to buy my
new critical condition we were able to
establish an efficient protocol
to go for producing high proportion of
bx+
Nek X 6.1 positives pancreatic
progenitors from human glued important
stem cell and maximizing their
deliberative capacity
so we generated a noble population of
Nek acceptable to one Buddha that cell
PDX one positive and negative salt
devoid of EDX station that may be a new
source of beta cells
so all of the confusion
to call
the cables so you want a potent stem
cells we use the h1 and the Mei MRI 90
IBS cell human umbilical Heineman
district endemic stem cells were then
translated into Bank really progenitor
cash flow using the West republished
protocols by industry which has been
published in Stanford reports in 2015 we
use the same protocol we have to blow
the poppy stream protocol in the fan
pick one protocol the first one they
holding and adherence and what Clayton
and the only difference between the two
go to call on mr. stream especially
input a cold one for them was only two
days and the stage stream for the other
protocol was four days and then they
claimed that will extend the mr. stream
you will have in the x1 positive NK
accessible to an negative which you will
never give function because of but
shortening the [ __ ]
will give function or the bubble
positive be the X 1 and X 6.1 so we use
the same protocol with the Clyde
purification so here you finally because
of the reagent that we use what we did
with the sample to code will reduce the
data and then we stop or the with
associated record after stage one after
the endodermal square so the direct
reading they for musicians about and we
replaced them on fresh matrigel for new
place mattress coated place in different
very still and using the same protocol
what we found
and then by doing this we find that we
were able to enhance the Gong creative
differentiation because we really
manipulating the extracellular matrix
the fresh method method William fresh
material the cell dynasty and give the
cell chance to be to be read faster and
we for example we use 250 to 300
thousand cells with the world so that
the endodermis cells divided into two so
only half of the epidermal cells were
the plated so one plate for two capes
and at the end we we differentiate the
progenitor into pancreatic endocrine
progenitor and them insulin clicking
cells
so within them vertical one at the
protocol through protocol one a protocol
to dissociated advantage issues
associated with our protocol
you
so the density as I mentioned is 206
300,000 of 350
we genetically population of pancreatic
progenitor
so how will give it industry populations
as I mentioned first we differentiated
into do mechanical and different content
to them which is the source of bank
areas but chaotic presenter and the
bacteria so we make sure that we have
high efficiency depreciation protocols
we look around above 94% and will
confirm this way moon staining by a
closed circulatory and other methods and
it's expressed subsequently in unbox a
to
and we generated in akhira the BBX was
it at any case export one pocket as far
as previously reported by nostril and
also we generated that BD x negative
sorry buildings positive any case six
point two one negative which is we fully
hood moment as we agreed and order alpha
cell
however with a slight modification we
find that we could generate new
population it's only a nickel six point
one positive and all surrounded by the
other population whether that the one
that is only big X ability or the double
positive attitude for genetics from each
one human embryonic stem cells and then
we simply reproduce just confirm at this
detail or this technique using other
sperm line so we use the I break you
regenerating the three populations using
the new to go bottom stem cells
the same please not you you can notice
that very clear distinction between the
indicates exclusive assault will direct
with with a double positive or PDX one
article
so then we start to optimize our the
transition protocol to generate that the
maximum or the highest efficient
protocol to reduce the double booster
cell types because this solve it can be
used to treat diabetic patient
so in order to increase the size of the
genetic be the exporters of any kxx code
to ability population in our protocol we
hope to dissociate and replayed as I
mentioned in the protocol then the data
machine before after the Ndebele when
developers want to [ __ ] it into single
cell and we related a domino baya
difficult gates this cells were
subjected to the same protocols p1 and
p2 as I mentioned so for each this
protocol we can put the efficiency of
pancreatic head induction between
undissociated which is based on the
strong and dissociated based on our
protocol as you can see here the number
associated one deep double positive
but in comparison to our protocol
it's higher efficiency and also this
kind of associated but
undissociated not give much
double-booked ourselves and buy one that
is not giving like it's only be the x+
week's big concern and we we exemplified
by image training and by career kinda
char and the pcr is different techniques
and we can show you the same thing the
transcription factors particularly the
bubble Bilitis transcription practice so
there's a BD x one and any case expert
one what highly expressed significant
big plays in comparison to other
protocol
then we get some then we compared now we
know that this to protocol visit of the
protocol can give us enough double
positive order are good quality double
Boudicca speedy x1 and X 6.1 Baluchistan
so we we analyze several package we
examine several practice as you can see
here in the client we exam in the cake
6.2 a successor nine so six nine is also
execute democratic parameters and then
comparison to the one man and associated
it's a grammatical English and the
double boosted so we have around like
90% as examined by Sigma thing
so we updated that after we learned that
although the dissociated cells were
regulated in any smaller number than
those of non dissociated fell the
densities of the south in our group
dissociated plate were higher at the end
of stage four which is about greater
than center stage
just in that if I increase in
preparation of the dissociated cells
don't rip it into the skateboarder the
invert the improvement in the
dissociation efficiency is related to
the changes in the separation we
analyzed the DNA density at the cell
cycle
at different time points during the
differentiation into progenitor so these
are the example we did several analysis
to analyzing the third of the four
protocols
at day 9 of differentiation showed a
market include nad in the attention
redoing completion
cells of b2 dissociated which is our
optimized protocol and compare it to
other protocols and consistency with
this PS EU integration result cell cycle
if you see the g1
since I can analysis showed that the
distribution of g1 s and g2 and phase
was changed so a reduction in the
proportion of cells in g1 say in
comparison to the other protocol
the increase in the dilation subspace
we also use the another profession
battle which is
ki-67
make sure that that sells about that
indicate 6.1 help this is mainly from
that in case except confirm positive
cells mm is painting and analyzing using
flow cytometry was found that ki-67 a
depression marker I will ensure that the
person theory of the some codes are
written both of them
one key 6mm or six nine and the KPI six
seven will higher in our protocol
- done and associated protocol this
indicates that
this isn't forget that the combination
of dissociation and replacing in the
dermis cells with extension we extended
stitch Forks as the original history
increasingly in the 8th interject and
the second progression
that's why we have high number of
pancreatic patient does not only this
but we as you know
in order to publish characterize the
efficiency power optimise the protocol
we examine the effect of the situation
on hepatic specification wine perfect
because hepatic and pancreatic
differentiation go together
you need from the same origin from
listen to and do that so mRNA level as
you can see by real-time PCR and PCR the
TV budget marker like alpha-fetoprotein
and Anton were dramatically reduced when
we the blade themselves the she sodium
and the ultimate fresh material
comparison test result that number
associated or they continue until the
incredible unit research so as you can
see here it's very clear so and also the
new staining aqua photography you can
see dramatic reduction in our optimize
the protocol
so this also suggests that the
dissociation of endoderm at the fish
matrix dramatically inhibit the hepatic
hm robotics managed by down-regulating
the exhibition deadly button genes
thereby improving the efficiency lived
in Connecticut appreciation
next we exam be the x12 Asian to
generate so we wanted to test whether
our progenitors with high efficiency 90%
was a double border in the video on any
cake 6.1 this so they were able to give
endocrine to goes to a next stage or not
the valley does the development the
potential of the double visited South
generated using our protocol we further
differentiate them translate them into
in the cry in the end endocrine stage
which is stage 5 pixels remained at the
stage line but you can see nearby limb
staining a stage file it's a decline a
stage it's characterized by the
expression of knowledge industry and for
short chroma Grandin which is globally
in the crime marker but normally the
imaging machine is transliterated it's
expressed temporary in this theorem
dissertation so the cells which are
battle difficult with MKX 6.1 and in
industry they always go to beat
ourselves so all on all implies cells go
through in GM's three-page but the cell
which is got ability for MKX export wine
are the only cells can be difficult so
we use the tool in decline mark
contingency and the chroma Grameen and
we do with the double staining works in
the config second one we find most of
the soldiers are double positive
indicating them
in their way to beta cells
so the next step was also to check with
a liquid it can give insulin-secreting
cells a map this was not published but
what will be done at stage 7 after step
6
chorus page 7 we examine the execution
of any cake 621 and the glucagon usually
indicate 6 with one at later still is
not expressing ourselves only exhibiting
beta cell
beta cells so and also exam of the
instrument and the biblical goal as I
mentioned before that only sells the
responsibilities are caplet many more
more ourselves one or more not one of
insulin-secreting cells so we find most
of the cells are motor hormonal as you
can see
so and then so now we can read that that
we generated very efficient protocol to
produce but the otic progenitor that can
be functional beta cell then we played
with the current condition using we
played with the Federation will be dealt
with fresh matrix cell density sidled
associations we then were played with
the number of ablated cells so in order
to to further optimize the
differentiation protocol we evaluated
the effective regulating that at
different densities as explained in the
previous slide regulated at high density
which is 250 to 300 thousand thousand
per centimeter square about half of the
dynasty of the genitive in the dermis
all give us the highest efficiency for
generation ability x1 mak 6.1
we found that dissociating the cells and
relating them in about 1/4 not only 1/2
1/4 the thermistors around 100,000
150,000 thousand or centimeter squared
resulted an appearance of
three-dimensional structures which
stained budgeted for indicates X 0.1
so these structures because are the same
cell but just were plated ordinary at
different density so as I mentioned
before this salt we give double
positives that we know that will go to
be resolved but interestingly they won't
let them and low number they give up 3d
structures and which in restructured is
everywhere in the culture and this
sleeve the structure when you
demonstrate them you find they are only
in cake six point one positive and the
negative form EDX one and the aluminum
surrounded by the double positive or by
BD Excel that means indicating that it
seems that during development the they
they go together or they they already
exist during development but the
function of this kind of progenitor we
don't know
we need to transcendental them into
animal models of the can share them in
virtual is what one work on now
start to characterize them whoa to
understand what are those structures or
societal structure but people they are
always associated with the other
progenitors then we characterize them we
double mixed in with so many markers in
the credit market but here I will just
show some of them for example indicate
fixable indicate 6.3 indicate x2y2
transcription factors it's known that
it's in the endocrine it's involved in
the current development in a human it
has been found that this marker is
accelerated into cranberry castle count
but is not exceeded at early stages so
double immunogenic a dependency here
showed that some of them pursue the
negative 4b dx1 some of these structures
were posited for any X equal to 2 day 2
3 so and the negative
indicating that businesses of indicating
depth they may be they go to do in the
crime stage but we're negative or coma
grass
so in Texas mode one also involved with
em also involved with in battle
development so we tested the ductile
development so this population we
investigated whether this porosimetry
population introduced ductile markers
and we'll find that it's equal to 6 9 I
didn't show it here but then we kissed
for sex to kratom 19 which is a specific
marker for differentiated buccal cells
for pancreatic progenitor ranges in
monolayers the normal one the doctor
marker was explained about not in the
same Nek 6.1 but in case of progenitor
it was totally positive they were
certainly positive or negative for
security 19 this indicate that it is not
involved with inventory at exactl
development
to the conclusion
we published the most efficient protocol
to generate the categories enter that
can generate functional big results
manipulating
manipulating cars shipment within the
facility the density and self in contact
and it's circular mapping our essential
element in improving than creating the
transition efficiency under corporation
which invaded global vegetable identity
that may be involved in a lineage back
to generate precursor in lumen
further studies will continue to
completely characterize the local
population and identified state and rule
in the creative development so our novel
methods could serve as a source of high
liberal creative team up low potential
dreaded bank records progenitor
providing the platform for features
capital production or functional because
LM better so at the end of my talk I
would like to thank my team and funding
organization thank you very much